el presidente de donald trump anunció
que espera nominar a su candidato de la
próxima semana y que muy probablemente
será una mujer
será una mujer una mujer muy talentosa
muy brillante
a quien no he elegido todavía pero
tenemos muchas mujeres en la lista entre
los nombres que ya suenan está en icon y
va a ver quién es considerada como la
candidata más fuerte de 48 años integra
la corte de apelaciones del séptimo
distrito jose de chicago y tiene buena
reputación entre los círculos más
conservadores también estaría la jueza
cubano americana bárbara lagoa de 52
años la primera de origen latino en la
corte suprema de florida y a quien trump
calificó el sábado como una persona
extraordinaria
joanne larsen y alison eight son otras
de las opciones femeninas que tendría el
mandatario estadounidense que pretende
llenar la vacante que deja ruth báder
ginsburg en la corte suprema antes de
las elecciones presidenciales del 3 de
noviembre en las calles de washington
decenas de personas pidieron el sábado
que se honre el deseo de la magistrada
quien antes de morir dijo que la
nominación debería hacerla la persona
que gane la carrera a la casa blanca una
recomendación compartida por el
candidato demócrata a la presidencia yo
byd en los jueces de la corte suprema de
estados unidos
son nombrados por el presidente y luego
tienen que ser confirmados por el senado